hi guys and this video I want to talk about
the uniqueness of coconut oil it has some
real interesting properties that I want to
discuss number one it is or fifty percent of
it is MCTS medium chain triglycerides now what
are those those are a type of fat that doesn't
necessarily convert to fat it's used it's
energy and its really good to induce more
fat burning so it will help you lose weight if
the fat that helps you lose weight and also it's
very friendly to your liver and gallbladder
so it doesn't involve a lot of the bile and
the liver to actually digest this fat because it
immediately goes right into the lymph system through
your intestines and it's used for energy so it's
really good for people with liver problems and
gallbladder issues okay so that's really cool it
has lauric acid there's really only two or three
things that I know I think palm oil coconut oil
and and breast milk that have lauric acid lauric
acid is a very powerful antiviral antimicrobial
type of fat that helps decrease viruses it helps
your immune system it's really good for Candida
and funguses so it's a good thing for your immune
system so coconut oil is good for the immune
system good for fat burning good for energy it
also helps you get into ketosis that's fat burning
because when you're in ketosis you need something
like fat to allow you go from one meal to the
next that's one of the reasons you should see
some my recent videos and I'll put some links
down below on these keto bombs keto fat bums
so I have a lot of different recipes now that
I'm putting out there to give people ideas to
camouflage coconut oil like like how you going
to eat coconut you're going to just like put on
a spoon well you can make little cookies with it
and then you can keep them the freezer the fridge
and consume them at the end of the meal so it's
a way that I consume more fat to allow you to not
be so hungry and go from one meal to the next so
you can burn more fat so it does help ketosis vs.
going on some low calorie thing or low fat meal
that's really bad and also actually it promotes
good cholesterol and it actually improves your
cholesterol profiles so coconut oil is really
good for your hair as well good for the skin it's
good for a lot of things so I just want to point
these out go ahead and start consuming coconut oil
if you haven't already but go ahead and click the
link below and I have some recipes for you called
keto fat balms check it out thank you for watching